[Music]
this video will be about the many
adaptations and designs of the dreaded
monsters called the cranium repton
are also called the skull crawlers that
was seen in the 2017 kong skull island
movie
they are large reptilian creatures with
only two long folims
and no legs as well as long prehensile
serpentine tails
but we won't just be describing their
appearance and structure
but also dive in into the inspirations
for the makers of the movie to create
such an intimidating creature we will be
taking a few points on where they came
up with the body structure of these
monsters
and their faces their blood loss and
also their eyes the jaws
and other features many were taken from
other fictional monsters but some were
also adapted from real life creatures so
here it goes
the body let us start with the body of
the skull crawler
as you can all see it has a very long
tail and two legs but no four limbs
or it might be the other way around two
four limbs and no legs
as original as it may seem for a giant
creature that has to fight another giant
creature
it won't be the first time such a design
has been put forth by
film producers in fact the first ever
giant monster movie
the one with king kong himself has such
an animal
it was called the two-legged lizard and
this is one of the only officially
stated inspirations for the design
of the skull crawlers this creature
appeared to be climbing a cliff in one
of the scenes in the 1933 king kong
flick
it won't be the only creature to inspire
a king kong villain in modern remakes
the other being the t-rex which gave way
to the 2005
vastatosaurus rex the face so if you
look at the face of the skull crawler
it looks like it is just a skull without
any skin or flesh to cover it up
even though it had a thin layer of skin
over the skeletal features
the looks of the creature seems to reek
of death and decay
the inspirations of this strange facade
comes from two of anime's very popular
franchises
one being pokemon and the other being
spirited away
the pokemon that resembles the crawler's
face is the cubone
and from spirited away it would be no
face since the skull crawler had to
represent a hyper carnivore
that was also a kaiju it was in need of
a fresh facial design
not covered by toho in the past thus
came the skeletal features inspired by
anime
the exoskeleton going down from the head
and face
we come to the body and especially the
upper torso and not surprisingly enough
it also has the skeletal features that
seem to protrude from the skin
and outwards like a pseudo exoskeleton
protecting the creatures
insides for this part of the body the
designs came from the xenomorph of the
alien franchise
the cinema of aliens are the ultimate
life forms and they had some sort of
bony exoskeleton that covered
the entire body especially the ribs and
the shoulders which were also seen in
the skull crawler's designs
as the ribs seemed to protrude out of
the body and even the spine from the
back
and a prehensile tail the jaw so
going back to the head we forgot to
discuss about a very important feature
which is the jaw
although it is a part of the face of the
skull crawler we decide to discuss it
separately
as the monster had the jaws that were
very similar to that of the mosasaurus
and what is the mossosaurus you say it
is an extinct marine reptile that lived
during the time of the dinosaurs and
died out along with them
this creature had a very long and
slender snout and teeth that were
conical and sharp
excellent for grabbing and tearing apart
flesh
these extinct creatures had very
powerful jaw strength as well
with a bite force of 33 000 pounds per
square inch
which was at least as powerful as the
tyrannosaurus rex
the eyes now for the eyes and most
notably
what appears to be the eye sockets of
their skull-like heads
are merely empty openings their real
eyes are set much further back
with the opening or sockets perhaps
serving to distract enemies from their
more vulnerable eyes
and they also act as heat-seeking
sensory pits
a real-life animal that has such an
adaptation is the king of the oceans
a killer whale's eyes are on each side
of its head just behind
and above the corner of its mouth and in
front of its white
eye spot the most popular theory is that
the orca eye spots
protect their actual eyes by providing a
false target
and in the same way the skull crawlers
also evolved to have false eye spots to
distract enemies
the reptilian guilds in the novelization
it is stated that the skull crawlers are
amphibious
as we were mentioned as one in the
boneyard
had gills this is similar to the monster
verse godzilla who is also a reptile
but strangely possesses guilds but the
question arises as to why they never
left the island
and go out hunting somewhere else well
for one these
skull crawlers are hyper carnivorous and
were in a constant state of starvation
and hunting in the open seas would have
taken way too much of their energy
as they might not be so much adapted to
catching fishes and marine life forms
therefore they might have just died in
the open seas
but they did try to reach out to
ghidorah's alpha call
but were killed by kong when they tried
to leave the island
the mimicry the novelization states that
the skullcrawlers can mimic human cries
and that this was the reason and cause
of gunpei ikari's death
as he and marlow mistook one for an
eewee child crying
the book also suggests that the largest
skullcrawlers appeared
when it did because it somehow sensed
that kong was down
and might have understood and heard
certain sounds that were familiar
to when kong's parents cried out in pain
the inspirations
for the skull crawlers adaptation is
taken from the predator this alien can
imitate sounds of humans and use it to
lure them into a trap during a hunt
this feature was also seen in wrath of
the titans
when the minotaur actually mimicked
human sounds to attract perseus and the
others
the blood lost skullcrawlers possess
accelerated metabolism which causes them
to live in constant starvation
this is shown when the big one
ravenously tried to eat weaver
and refused to let go of gong's arms it
was also shown that
they have a deep desire of killing and
eating humans which was shown several
times when
the big one diverted his attention from
kong to james conrad
and mason weaver implying that he acts
not only from primal instinct but also
some degree of malice and cruelty
this is quite reminiscent of the way the
vastatosaurus rexes of the 2005 king
kong movie
acted towards and arrow in the scene
where they were battling kong
but also trying to eat them both even in
near-death situations for them
from falling off the cliff and hanging
on vines they just wouldn't stop
the tongue the skull crawlers had
prehensile tongues that were used to
grab
and quickly devour small prey and all
for gripping large spray in combat
the usage of these tongues was seen very
clearly throughout the movie as
when they were tracking the scent of
humans and also
during the scene in the boneyard when
one of the skullcrawlers quickly shot
out its tongue like a chameleon
and in a very fast movement quickly
pulled the person back into its mouth
this adaptation is seen in real life
chameleons and other lizards
the fork design of the tongue however is
an adaptation seen in snakes
as they capture scent in the air to
track down their prey
so before we end the video do check out
our teespring store as we have mind cue
mops
tees hoodies masks phone cases and more
we love your support if you like the
marks then there are two titan
silhouette designs on both sides of one
and we paired godzilla with ghidorah
rodan and mothra
and the other titans as well so grab one
for a fresh cup of coffee
we also update our stove every once in a
while with new designs
so now we come to the end of this video
so do like share and subscribe
and for the ones that are always there
thank you for your support
and for the new ones please subscribe
and hit that notification bell
for regular updates